the Gothard theater is silent save for
the occasional shifting of your fellow
Foundation researcher the two of you are
alone and you've been tasked with
transcribing the performance of
scp-6373 you read the file understood
the briefing and you even told yourself
that you're prepared to witness whatever
obscene show is about to commence but
you've never experienced
scp-6373 first hand this is your first
time filling in for another researcher
who got herself injured during one of
the performances you hope it wasn't
anything serious the lights flash
pointing to the main stage the smell of
rot is almost overwhelming now you swear
you see a family of rats Scurry under
your front row seats the curtains fly
open revealing nothing you expect
someone to come out from behind the
curtain but the stage is Barren suddenly
a loud creaking noise is heard from
above and 4 broken poorly painted and
utterly deranged looking puppets dropped
from the ceiling their strings are
slightly visible and their movements
fluctuate between quick jerky motions
and slow weighty ones the one with the
long nose starts talking in a
high-pitched lofty voice asking the
desolate audience if they're ready for
the show you start to wonder when things
are going to kick in and really cement
this anomaly status as a terrifying SCP
object for the first five minutes the
show isn't too bad the puppets sing and
dance a bit creepy but they're not doing
anything wrong at least that's what you
think until the long-nosed one
brandishes a baseball bat and savishly
smashes the smaller round one to a pulp
splattering guts and insides all over
the theater and it only gets worse from
there welcome to the Gothard theater the
home of
scp-6373 codenamed by those researching
it as stage blight
scp-6373 refers to a collection of four
paper mache puppets each standing around
one meter in height and complete with
attached strings these puppets
constantly emit a rotting disgusting
stash though the foundation has come to
the conclusion that this smell is
entirely non-anomalous
scp-6373 gained their anomalous
properties at around 6 PM each day as
long as they're positioned inside the
Gothard theater a building located in
the City of Reading Pennsylvania which
is where the foundation has chosen to
contain the four objects if
scp-6373 aren't inside the Gothard
theater they instead start decomposing
rotting and breaking down into a stinky
smelly mess of puppet materials so what
happens when
scp-6373 takes on their anomalous
properties the puppets gain sentience
mobility and limited intelligence though
attempts to communicate with
scp-6373 outside of their performances
have failed sorry no puppet interview
logs for today they then proceed to the
main stage of the Gothard theater and
put on a puppet show wow a whole
performance isn't that sweet not really
scp-6373's performances are notoriously
brutal unpredictable and terrifying so
much so that the foundation has offered
counseling services to the poor
Personnel forced to watch them that's
right there must be at least one
observing Personnel in the Gothard
theater to witness
scp-6373's performance or else the
puppets drop to the floor and start
decomposing again following their
performance the puppets lose all
sentience until 6 pm on the next day
where the process repeats but let's talk
about
scp-6373 themselves these puppets have a
lot of character you have Pierre SCP 6
d373-1 the main character of the
performances who just loves to verbally
and physically abuse his fellow wooden
companions gluten
scp-6373-2 is a large disembodied head
with a gaping mouth who speaks only in
single word statements and deep guttural
moans
scp-6373-3 is a tiny gray round ball
known as Emi who remains entirely silent
throughout the performances despite
being the puppet abused by the others
the most frequently the puppet
scp-6373-4 Jacques is a long-necked
clown who serves as the group's comedic
relief but before we delve into the
horrific performances put on by these
entities let's talk about the Gothard
theater the theater was opened in 1860
by French immigrant Timothy goffard for
the purposes of putting on stage plays
musical performances and in-house puppet
shows that feature scp-60
2373 the puppets were designed by
Gothard himself and were massively
profitable and popular with reading's
children while it's not known if
scp-6373 possessed their anomalous
properties during the original run of
performances the foundation doesn't
believe they did and they were otherwise
ordinary puppets controlled by
puppeteers unfortunately the Gothard
theater was not built to last in 1884 it
closed its doors after a legal battle
between Gothard and his wife Cynthia
raged through the courts Cynthia was
accused of stealing money from the
theater to which she defended herself
saying that Timothy was not only
Unfaithful in their marriage but also
physically and verbally abusive to her
the lawsuit ended in a divorce and an
ominously worded letter written to
Cynthia by Timothy I write to you in
poor health and all Joyce sapped from my
life made Misfortune Follow You Until
the End of your days I will not
construct again that which I had spent
two decades of my life working towards I
can only think God's grace that the
building has remained vacant as I could
not bear to see it owned by another man
I want to perform again and see the
children smile my happiness was so
linked to theirs a week later Timothy
Gothard disappeared entirely four months
later Cynthia Gothard supposedly died of
natural causes in 1887 Foundation
precursor organization the American
Secure containment initiative or asci
for short discovered
scp-6373 inside the theater and
documented its anomalous properties
shortly after
scp-6373 had a captive audience and
containment persisted long after the
asci had assimilated into the SCP
Foundation and now we can get to the
part you've all been waiting for the
performances themselves the foundation
has kept a log of all the
scp-6373's performances but here are
some of the most notable ones
scp-6373's first performance in 1887
involved lighting fixtures around the
theater collectively powering on several
minutes before the show as well as a
slight piano accompaniment originating
from an unknown source the contents of
the show were simple Pierre rescued a
princess a costume Jacques from a dragon
played by gluten researchers noted
several moments where one of the puppets
had difficulty maintaining posture and
moving often taking multiple attempts to
lift limbs these moments increased in
frequency over time in 1895 the puppets
performed a show about a bank robbery
gone wrong Pierre decided that M.A was
the one who alerted the police about
their crime and spent the rest of the
performance berating and abusing the
small puppet specifically for betraying
its trust and Breaking the Bond they had
shared after years of working together
as Pierre put it the puppets use Emmy as
a soccer ball but their game quickly
devolves into a contest of trying to see
who can kick it the hardest and me is
noted to be silently crying throughout
all of this in 1916 the puppets put on a
World War one period piece taking place
on a farm owned by husband Pierre and
his wife Emmy Pierre upset that his
crops were destroyed by the ongoing War
asks ma for support but the puppet
remains silent even as Piers cries grow
louder and more frantic pure than shifts
the blame of the crop's destruction from
the war to a May itself he states that a
May will never be let out of the house
again sounds of war and human suffering
were heard throughout in 1922 the
puppets repeated their first performance
about the princess and the castle except
this time the puppet sounded a lot
angrier in their dialogue delivery and
their movements are described as frantic
bursts in in between moments where they
do nothing but hang limp Pierre yells at
gluten for an apparently poor
performance as the princess and when the
puppet pretends to play dead Pierre
specifically states that that's not what
being dead feels like in 1938 the
puppets attempted to perform a comedy
routine but quickly found out that their
slow unsynchronized movements were
causing problems with the pacing and
effectiveness of their act Pierre became
frustrated and brandished a prop fire
hose which he sprayed at the fellow
puppets causing them to scream as their
paint ran off and shipped their screams
heard throughout the theater were
notably feminine in 1952 Pierre
performed a piano duet with Jacques who
was unable to sit still or keep quiet
during the act the annoyed Pierre
proceeded to savagely slam Jacques head
into the piano until it was dented and
his jaw was detached completely the
Jacques puppet began leaking a
disgusting yellow fluid from its mouth
Pierre fetched Emmy and forced the tiny
puppet sit in the fluid all while
Jacques writhed in pain while the damage
sustained by the puppets during each
performance was healed and restored by
the next day through anomalous means
Jacques jaw was never fixed and he
continued to seep fluid for the duration
of the anomaly's containment 1958's
performance was only two minutes in
length and featured Pierre attempting to
teach an art class gluten's canvas
displayed the words open inside which
for some reason angered pure enough to
end the performance entirely and lead
the puppets off stage for the next 24
hours an unidentified male voice
screamed and swore from behind the
stages curtain throwing objects and
punching walls The Source was not
discerned and no
scp-6373 instances could be found within
the theater until the next day at 6 PM
when they re-emerge from the back and
performed as usual this 1963 performance
was particularly bizarre Pierre took the
stage by himself and proceeded to
deliver a eulogy for Timothy goffard in
the voice of an unidentified woman
strangely the foundation discovered that
a funeral service was not held for
Gothard in 1971 the puppet's
performances became a lot more lifeless
their voices became monotone and their
movements were slower oftentimes a
puppet would have to hit itself in order
to restore fluid motion to its limbs
this would continue in all future
performances in 1973
scp-6373 performed a sitcom skit in
which Pierre and his two sons played by
Jacques and gluten took turns beating
and breaking a me this trend of physical
abuse towards a May would increase in
frequency as time went on like in this
four hour 1976 performance that
consisted of the silhouette of the
puppets from behind the stage torturing
the poor thing all Walla Mae silently
took it all the while Pierre told them a
that it was the sole reason the puppets
were in their current situation and why
they were on able to move forward in
1979 the gothard's theater's structural
integrity was observed to be failing
masses of rats termites and fungi were
discovered throughout the building
similarly the performances themselves
became even more disturbing one involved
the puppets reenacting the life story of
Timothy goffard but refused to
acknowledge or mention his wife Cynthia
instead they claimed he died alone and
miserable without ever experiencing love
the performance ended with Pierre
smashing its head against the floor and
knocking it off unleashing a swarm of
blowfly larva the foundation was unable
to remove from the theater in 1983 the
puppets performed a skit in which they
held a funeral for M.A after exploring a
variety of possible afterlives from
various religions the puppets were
understandably confused about which one
was correct and how they could achieve
salvation then Jacques has an epiphany
exclaiming I know the answer we're all
dead this is the only afterlife there is
the puppets then went limp and stayed
there for a week by 1984 the puppets put
almost zero effort into their
performances what involved them openly
fantasizing about injuring the audience
members and ended with the puppets
picking a poor Foundation researcher
from the audience as a volunteer and
snapping her arm all while laughing
another had the puppets stating the full
names birthdays and death dates of every
patron of the Gothard theater from its
opening to the present and this included
the foundation researchers watching
scp-6373's movements were awkward and
slow their speech slurred it was clear
that the puppets were on their last limb
in 1985 every performance had
degenerated to a frenzy of self-harm
carried out by the puppet devoid of any
stage lighting and accompanied by a
noisy barely harmonious musical
accompaniment feminine screams and male
laughter is heard throughout but things
got even worse throughout the year as
performances further degraded to periods
of sitting or standing still and
incoherent rambling while facing the
audience the performances were entirely
indecipherable and all dialogue
consisted of grunting moaning screaming
and weeping on June 6 1985
scp-6373 put on another performance the
puppet stood side by side for 18 minutes
before bowing and falling to the ground
no lights or music was heard following
this performance the puppets began to
Decay shedding their paper mache
exteriors when this was complete the
insides of the puppets were revealed to
be composed of human remains and organs
Pierre contained a brain Jacques a heart
gluton a massive skin and tissue anime
was empty all of this material had been
cut cleanly and sourced from a single
individual when the foundation unrolled
the skin tissue contained inside the
gluten puppet there was no doubt about
which individual it resembled Cynthia
cortier the wife of Timothy goffard the
object was reclassified as neutralized
and no further performances or anomalous
activity relating to
scp-6373 was ever observed now go check
out scp-701 the Hang King's tragedy and
scp-5049 Demon dance discount homunculus
Depot for more scps that blur the line
between entertainment and Terror